une quinzaine d' historique du bo pas
dépendante east martiniquais qui demande
une assemblée générale pour régler les
problèmes au sein du parti bonjour silva
boli noir bonjour monsieur vous faites
partie de ce groupe de réflexion
patriotes qui montent au créneau pour
dénoncer des dérives jugé autocratique
de la part de son président alfred marie
jeanne pour qu'on en arrive à une telle
extrémité de la part de partie plutôt
discret voire secret sur son mode de
fonctionnement
c'est que l'heure est grave selon vous
c'est aboli noir vous savez
historiquement nous avons été un parti
révolutionnaire par conséquent et
d'ailleurs on pouvait vérifier que peu
de choses sont écrites
nous avions l'habitude du sucre chez
nous et cette crise
vous le savez très bien est née il ya
presque deux ans ils ont pas loin de 18
mois depuis le 9 décembre 2016
nous avons attendu nous avons écrit nous
avons envoyé des courriers nous avons
fait toutes sortes d'interventions pour
que les problèmes puissent régler en
interne on ne nous répond pas et au lieu
de nous répondre
on nous salit publiquement eh bien nous
avons tenu suffisamment longtemps
et puisque la chose a été dévoilée à
l'extérieur du mime papa ou non mais pas
le président eh bien nous étions obligés
alors sur la forte réponse à sion sur la
forme d'abord un tel groupe avec de
telles personnalités du mit qui se
réunissent pour disent non c'est ce qui
se passe comme ça comme vous l'avez fait
hier ç'a dû faire désordre vous avez eu
des réactions depuis votre conférence de
presse je vous laisse seul juge
en tout cas en ce qui me concerne il me
semble que pour la première fois ils
vont ne partait de la population
num soupe nous supporter et d'ailleurs
dans le parti vous avez dû vous remarqué
que de nombreux militants supporte la
démarche parce que nous n'avons pas
demandé la tête du président nous
n'avons pas demandé sa démission
nous n'avons pas demandé son exclusion
sommes nous reconnaissons nous le
reconnaissons président mais ce que nous
disons il faut que les choses reviennent
comme par le passé
tout simplement vous avez quand même
entendu que vous ne pouviez pas être à
la fois en dedans et en dehors etc en
organisant cette conférence de presse
hier
vous vous exclure y est vous même
automatiquement directement du mime
je crois savoir que à la conférence de
presse nous avons remis aux journalistes
présents
un document dans ce document il y avait
des statuts les statuts qui soigne et
par le secrétaire à l'organisation qui
l'a même lui-même signé mais décembre
lors des entretiens contre la dengue
le document signé cosigné paraphé par le
trésorier par deux secrétaires et par le
président du mouvement des protistes
martinique 1 en décembre 2011 alors
pourquoi ce secrétaire général à
l'organisation at il prétendu
publiquement en en réunion et terne du
mouvement indépendantiste martiniquais
que ses statuts n'existait pas il
faudrait peut-être le lui demander en
tout cas ces statues apparemment existe
puisque nous les avons récupéré à la
préfecture de martinique
donc le seul document que l'état
français à sa possession concernant le
mime seychelles document là on y
reviendra
nous le reconnaissons et j'allais dire
que dans ce document il n'y a aucun
article vous pouvez le vérifier
permettant de dire que quelqu'un qui va
à une conférence peut être exclue ça
n'est pas possible ça n'existe pas sauf
si on considère que nous sommes dans un
pays de non droit dans une république
bananière ou dans une dictature alors
c'est d'abonnés noir puisque vous avez
dit que ses statuts ont été déposés
en préfecture si cette conférence de
presse qui s'est tenue hier ce que vous
dénoncez
ce que vous demandez une assemblée
générale a pour tout régler si ça ne
fonctionne pas vous seriez prêt à
retourner devant les instances pour
faire avancer votre dossier vous aurez
férié alors aux instances de la
république française non je n'ai pas dit
cela
ce que je veux dire c'est que
publiquement
tout le monde est au coût moins je
l'espère la population l'opinion
publique fera la pression qu'il faut et
je réside dans leur résidence le veut le
président lever ou pas tôt ou tard il
devra se conformer ce que pense un peu
plus il est beau les militants y ait ou
des caddies coup militants officielle du
mime depuis 1985
tout monde qu'on ait des personnalités
alfred marie-jeanne est ce qu'on va
passer franchement que parce qu
autrefois conférence de presse et puis
jazz montrent que alfred marie jeanne
qui a changé attitude comportement
vis-à-vis des autres
mon candidat et qui change est il
condamné à changer pièce partis
politiques par exister sans les
militants les militants c'est nous c'est
ben ali alors roy dit pdt ni peut-être
15 présenter nicaise les 15 qui présents
sont les membres de du collectif mais
c'est par quinzaine qu'il a à titre
d'exemple il casse - mettez ni le droit
aussi nul au député une météo aussi adam
réunion comité national officiel d'entre
nous ont été atteints aux eaux au motif
que kyle à settat moins un mètre a
constaté que les médias dits qualif en
réunion vendu à 10 passes et gaumont et
pathé nissan en tout cas et qu à saint
marc rfo teddy à grignan samedi ni lola
t nip au moins 500 morts
donc ça veut dire que qui l'équipe
allait jodias population
jacques a contesté ces méthodes là mais
c'est vous même qui dit que ni statut de
joker puisqu'au total et ses statuts
tard pour dial fred barry jeunes
changent et attitudes changent et
comporte à sion comme un dea en
assemblée générale son bac si pendant
longtemps c'est pas facile et sécurisé
ça veut dire au statut puisque statut
est à prévoir tous les trois un
fauconnier en renouvellement
ah ben je suis ni thil depuis 2011 en
fait c'est depuis 2010
ça tue à déposer des petits en 2011 mais
depuis 2010 nous panier à simplifier
alors jugnot 2018
alors combien assemblée générale qui se
passait nous a changés trésorier que
juillet a kick a signé chez claudia nous
ils parlent et statutaires jette bien
imager ça ça veut dire ligne un certain
nombre de discussions mais s'il veut
bollénois même la mort du père compagne
puisque nous manque comité national le
ministre ou du comité national encore
moment du conseil national où le monde
du conseil national si nitoo ça n'en est
que caisse assemblée générale parfaite
notamment tour que d'autres mots des
bêtes à plumes on est quelques pas
complices dans quelle situation d'où
nous car ça fait un moment notamment day
à l'intérieur ouais parce que nous avoue
mais parce que new delhi que tout
problème réglé à l'intérieur monsieur
des militants de longue date nous nous
pas télé ça transpire et des oies mais
les au cas où et que depuis élections
légistatives là et notamment depuis que
jean philippe nolot réélu brillamment on
doit constater que si tu as changé qu'il
gagne en escalade cela je dis assez les
militants du mime qui à la limite ni
anti penche à carson qui n'y at il pas
un chien pour janvier définis lors et
biographe vilipendé haut au moment où la
martinique vision redressement au moment
où les martiniquais voté à alfred marie
jeanne pour témoigner ce pays a au
moment où alfred marie-jeanne même à de
confiance de poster fait hier qu'a dit
que la situation est difficile que
les rentrées d'argent sont faibles que
les transferts diminué de l'état vers la
collectivité
ollier attaché colis à ça pour essayer
rugby ce pays au moment où la jeunesse
cas content l'oeil sur mon mental cake à
trouver pour passer d'un a fait de
l'invectivé et à taper à sauver jean
philippe nolot nos pratiques et aux
courses et franchement qu'elle nous paie
pas accepter sans aucun passé
franchement très naïve droit au sens du
rêveur sylvain bruneau alors à penser
que alfred marie jeanne qui émettait un
dialogue beaucoup d autres pourtant ne
peut changer en situation qui quittait
dépit de l'année en tout cas de priver
la plus à l'est de la cité m
alfred marie jeanne c'est un nom alfred
marie-jeanne c'est pas un robot alfred
marie-jeanne ne s'est pas machine lieu
toujours à point de moins que la
biologie
c'est un bague à équiper changes et par
conséquent n'a qu'à penser que les quais
way que pesson bat à supporter a dans
ses gaffes et à part un petit groupe de
tueries fait larguer à lentilly notre
côté au nom ni aux moyennes quitté gagné
le statut de coparent ouais pourquoi pas
directement de tamaris est sûre à gages
et la rénovation
si les béninois s'ils allaient pas
changé est ce que vous êtes capables
pour la direction criant d'autres partis
non nous pas pour l'instant ça va
intéresser nous que et de tentes pas
adapei dallas année à ces parties et
jamais mené trois pattes ils nous pas
pour le fractionné ce même si au cas
très dénudée fractionnistes nook a dit
le ministre nous le même si l'ensemble
des militants le même c'est l'ensemble
des sympathisants parce que fox à quai
les noirs au mime dans les années 85 et
ben le même thé café à peine 3000 voix
sur matinik faut qu'ça si la même rive
est haute et alain c'est parce que nous
tout travail nous passer une nuit
blanche non à l'époque ou debout tout
nous à l'époque où trois l'écouté à
l'effort de france c'est quand même
sylvain balling
été directeur de campagne les nous a
livré le gars c'était coup de fusil nous
du cac trapé les nouveautés et puis j'ai
un côté way that way ouvrir ou chat la
nuque rasée loto nous eh ben c'est sa
capacité à lanouf et à qui fait que le
même river au total a par conséquent
phoque
alfred marie-jeanne coûté autres merci
sylvain benoit donc rappelé qu au sepa
parole groupe réflexion patriote le mime
et l'acidité et puis non adam sont
crédibles mater monsieur
[Musique]